Allen let's go to you you have some
concerns about John Lott study and by
the way John I thought you were just
talking over me early I'm like God he
doesn't even hear what I say forgive the
audio this is live TV Alan let's talk to
talk to you about the methodology
without getting too wonky he paints a
picture of illegal immigrants more
likely to commit violent crime more
likely to be incarcerated for these
crimes murder manslaughter first degree
second degree
why do you dispute this well it's easily
disputed because the methodology just
doesn't work is inconsistent with every
other study that's been performed over
the last couple of decades as well as
data from the American Immigration
Association as well as the immigration
council which shows that immigrants
actually do less and the types of
creation now right well so row
immigration well I don't think they're
necessarily per immigration they're
pro-american but also Cato Institute is
also going out to the site for slurs
saying that there's statistics data
information so you gotta be kidding me
Alan you've got to do better than Cato
is notoriously open borders I mean they
are they dine out on China trade and
open borders we're not talking about dis
open borders we're talking about actual
information here and John there's no way
for John to actually have the data to
show who wasn't undocumented and who was
a legal immigrant his dad has really
skewed information from over a large
time period which just dumps American
naturalized citizens as well as people
who were here on the green card who were
in these removal proceedings which make
the numbers hyper alright John
respond quickly to that criticism please
yeah I mean there are a lot of points
they just brought up but it's trying to
say earlier is that there are a lot of
studies have been done but the problem
is is that those studies completely
mixed together legal and illegal
immigrants or they do surveys well in
the case of Arizona you have
pre-sentencing reports that are done
that determines whether or not
somebody's what their citizenship status
is that's included in the data that's
here now you know there may be some
issues that one can say that they may
have made mistakes in some cases but
even if you believe that's the case and
I doubt that the most you're talking
about is about 10 percent of the sample
that's there and that's very small
that's a much smaller error than any of
the other data that you've been pointing
to all right guys
fascinating and we're gonna continue to
debate this no doubt I think we need
more transparency more reporting more
truth in the localities the state should
have to reveal and keep a database on
who is committing the crime in the
United States the American people I
think demand to know Maryanne I know you
do